winning who is our executive director
for the Swart Center for
Entrepreneurship is going to be
providing an introduction for Alex Lasky
who is the president of a power perfect
hi everybody hi welcome to Carnegie
Mellon and Pittsburgh right April
weather and Pittsburgh's kind of like
Forrest Gump's box of chocolates you
never know what you're gonna get but
we'll puff it out here today really glad
to have Alex Lasky founder of Opower
with us today and we're gonna have an
opportunity for him to tell his story
we're gonna get kicked off by me asking
Alex a few questions and then open it up
to the audience huh there's a code up
there for you to text or email your your
your questions too and then I think
it'll be much better if we jump into the
audience quickly so that you guys can
get the questions that are on your mind
answered um what I'd like to do is maybe
just give a real brief overview or
biography of Alex before we start asking
questions because really this has been a
disruptive company Opower and you should
be very proud of it Oh powers technology
is transforming the way utilities relate
to their customers by combining data
management insightful analytics and
behavioral science Oh powers customer
engagement platform positions utilities
as the trusted energy adviser to the
customers they serve the company was
founded in 2007 and was publicly traded
on the New York Stock Exchange under
this the sticker Oh PWR before
ultimately being acquired by Oracle in
June of 2016 for six hundred and forty
million dollars so it's very successful
company
there are some other stats that are we
could talk about the company but maybe
they'll come out and sort of the
questions but that's all give Alex a
great big welcome
Carnegie Mellon in Pittsburgh welcome um
please tell us a little bit about your
career as it led up to Opower then what
you know why you started Oh power and
then ultimately took it public and sold
it to Oracle just to give everybody a
little bit of a background yeah first I
thank you for having me and thanks for
sticking around to the end of the day I
know there's alcohol that follows so I'm
not you know I won't we won't take too
much credit for you're still being here
but we appreciate it my career before ou
power I work primarily in politics I
never thought that I would go into
business I went I worked in politics
because I wanted to have a positive
influence on the world and still believe
politics can can be that path
I got particularly I was I should say
exceptionally good at coming my canit's
were exceptionally good at coming in
second or third place in their political
races so but but I became increasingly
interested in energy and environmental
policy and a old longtime friend of mine
from college danyay to approach me in
the summer of 2006 and said why don't we
do something together to have a positive
influence on the environment he had a
successful software startup and I said
that sounds like a great idea and after
the election that year when I worked on
a number of ballot measures and some
legislative campaigns that in spite of
my involvement actually succeeded we
started working together we sat at a
desk we sort of squatted in somebody
else's office and spent several months
trying to come up with an idea together
that we could pursue and that we would
enjoy pursuing together to have a
positive impact on the environment and I
you know maybe we can get to it later
but eventually the idea that sort of
stuck was this idea that nearly
everybody thinks saving energy is a good
idea and yet next and nobody wakes up in
the morning thinking how am I going to
save energy people have more important
more urgent or pressing things to worry
about and so we wondered if we could
create a better customer experience for
utilities and specifically if we could
replace the utility bill which at best
is for
and often frustrating and aggravating
and turn it into a better communication
to customers so as to inform motivate
them and ultimately help them change
their behaviors and that's how we
started the company and as you said
David we the company grew from 2007 from
the two of us to by the end there were
more than 600 of us at the company and
we went public we we eventually some
reluctance but it was the right thing to
do
handed the reins over to the folks at
Oracle and you know in terms of the
stats that I think about that I'm most
proud of visa via the company in its
history by the time we handed over the
company we were saving roughly five
terawatt hours of electricity every year
which to put that in perspective the
Hoover Dam produces 4.2 terawatt-hours
electricity a year so the impact that we
were having by giving people better
information and as Pittsburgh residents
perhaps you're familiar with the work we
do because we do Duquesne was and is a a
long time and very good partner we send
these communications through the mail
through email to customers in Pittsburgh
and across hundreds of cities in more
than a dozen countries that show you how
you compare to your neighbors and
similar sized homes and then provide
targeted recommendations of how you can
save energy and that was one of the many
things that we've done to help reinvent
the customer experience for utilities so
yeah that's very cool that's great over
if you're very transformative how many
Duquesne Light customers in the crowd
right so now you know where you're
getting that great information from so
this is an entrepreneurship panel and
about energy and entrepreneurship and so
I want to sort of roll back to the
beginning of your description there you
know what was the genesis moment what
was the aha moment that said you know
what we can do this this is real sure
it's a good question well there I think
there's there's a sort of mystique that
there's always one moment where pion
trapano realizes that they have a
brilliant idea or at least a good enough
idea that they're gonna pursue and I
actually think back on it with the
benefit or sort of maybe impediment of
time I actually think that there were
several moments that
starting the company you know we wanted
to work together and we wanted to work
together to have a positive impact on
the environment we sat down with six or
seven different ideas of things that we
thought we could do some of them were
for profit ideas some of them were not
for profit ideas but all of them had the
at least the end goal in mind to have a
positive impact on carbon emissions and
the inspiration for this particular idea
I think came largely from at the time
Dan had just returned from this epic
road trip he had taken with his
then-girlfriend
where they had started in the North
Slope of Alaska and driven down to
Tierra del Fuego Patagonia over the
course of nine months and the most
miraculous thing I guess about the drive
is that they their relationship survived
and they're now parents of two children
and happily married the other thing that
came out of that was dam was sort of
increasingly concerned about the
environment and wanted to do something
and came back and said we should do it
together but one of the legacies of the
trip was damn it at the time was driving
this old 4runner and which was fun to
drive and comfortable and I had this
tiny little Honda Civic but we found
quickly that we often took my Civic
instead of his 4runner because we were
even when we had our wives and at the
time girlfriends in the car because we
were concerned about the environmental
impact and we realized we had this sort
of aha moment of realizing you know each
of us knows how efficient our cars are
but we have no sense of how efficient or
inefficient our homes or apartments are
and they're probably lots of people
driving civics and the Prius had just
come out Priuses who live in Humvee
homes and don't even realize it so that
was sort of one insight we had but as I
said this was one of several ideas that
we were kicking around and we went we
went to the Hewlett Foundation and met
with a woman there named Rhea Suh who
was at the time a program officer at the
Hewlett Foundation she's now the
executive director or CEO of NRDC we sat
and met with her about a different
project we sat down we said look we were
thinking about a bunch of different
ideas but one of the ideas we have we
wanted
we thought about working with First
Nations peoples in British Columbia on
forest preservation and at the end of
the conversation she said well what are
some of your other ideas and I piped up
and I said well we we really would love
to give this idea to give people a
better utility bill show them how they
compare to their neighbors
give them targeted recommendations and
she said well surely you've read our
research on this and we said what
research and she said well dr. Child
Dinis research on behavioral science and
we said essentially what is behavioral
science and she pulled out of her filing
cabinet I think it was a paper copy of a
paper that they had funded which which
showed sort of the evidence for how you
would motivate people to in this case
turn off air-conditioning and turn on
fans and it was directly aligned with
our intuitions about what we would want
to do and she introduced us to dr. chal
Dina we went met with him he's the most
cited behavioral scientist in the world
his book influences is taught in most
business schools in the world translated
into dozens of languages and but this
was our introduction to it so that was
how we sort of you know you asked for
the aha moment I'm gonna give you I'll
give you one more part of the aha moment
or two pieces of it two more parts I
guess we were still bouncing around a
number of different ideas we were living
in San Francisco we had a meeting at
Stanford to talk about a concentrated
solar idea this was before solar and
with interested Dave Danielson's talk
about how solar has come down and cost
and now it's you know less than three
cents a kilowatt hour at the time it was
well over twelve thirteen cents a
kilowatt hour and even higher and there
was a big focus on how to concentrate
solar so we were meeting with some solar
concentrator folks from Lawrence
Livermore labs and also people at
Stanford and we showed up in Palo Alto
well over an hour early for our meeting
and I should say that neither Dan nor I
have ever been early for anything in our
lives and so I don't remember why we
were early but we were early and we got
to Palo Alto and I said you know instead
of having coffee let's go or maybe in
addition to having coffee let's go to
the Palo Alto util
the Palo Alto runs its own Municipal
Utility and we had heard on the radio
each of us a guy from the Palo Alto
utility is talking about their green
energy program and I said let's see if
we can meet with him and tell him about
our idea about the utility bill Dan
reluctantly agreed who took the we went
into the Municipal Building we went up
to whatever eighth floor we went to the
front desk where people come and pay
their bills and we said is the guy who
in charge of green energy here we heard
him on the radio and they said oh yeah
Brian Ward let's see if he's available
and they went back and sure enough Brian
was available and he met with us for 40
minutes we pitched him on our idea and
he said I would be your first customer
without a doubt I'll be your first
customer if you guys actually decide to
do this let me know and I'll happily
make other introductions and so on we
left the office I was doing sort of you
know jumping up in the air and clicking
my toes like dancing in the rain and I
singing in the rain dancing too and I
said to Dan that's it let's do this
business is gonna be great and Dan
looked at me and said you're crazy right
and I said no I'm being serious he said
but this is Palo Alto this is not the
rest of the world this is some weird
appealing but weird an unusual town and
they have 15,000 utility customers we're
not starting a business that's gonna
have some impact on that 15,000
customers you have to convince me and
convince us that this is worth pursuing
and it has scale and so and this is the
last aha moment they'll mention we can
get to your other questions and but I
told Dave actually before we started
that if I go along on anything he should
just cut me off this is so good okay so
we went we went I got in touch with the
folks who put us in touch with both
sides of the political spectrum in Texas
and and Texas does have more than one
side of its political spectrum and we we
went we got on the phone and talked to a
guy named Smitty
Will Smith William Smith I think is his
first name goes by Smitty
he ran Public Citizen he's now retired
but he ran Public Citizen in Texas and
at the time they were focused on
shutting down coal plant
in Texas and they were very successful
we told him about our idea he said this
is terrific and then we also met we also
talked on the phone with a dubbed
William dub Taylor who went by dub and
had been appointed by Governor George
Bush when he was governor to run the
State Energy Office and as far as I know
he's still in charge of the State Energy
Office in Texas he also was very
enthusiastic about what we were doing
and he said you ought to come down here
because the state legislature is meeting
and in Texas the state legislature meets
once every two years for basically three
months and we have a bill on energy
efficiency and so we bought Southwest
Airlines tickets we went down to Austin
we made mock-ups of our our product we
called it the Lone Star energy report
and we went and met with the author of
the legislation who now is the head of
the Speaker of the House in Texas at the
time he was a lowly Republican
legislator from San Antonio and and we
met with his staffer understand first
said to us look this sounds exciting
this is great I'll put it in the bill
but if anybody objects to it I'm gonna
get rid of it because we've got bigger
fish to fry they were trying to improve
building standards and appliance
standards and a bunch of other things
and Dan spent a couple days I spent five
days sort of wearing out the leather in
my shoes meeting with everyone I could
meet with in the in the state
legislature and the governor's office
lieutenant governor's office the
utilities and ventually got everybody to
either be supportive or most people sort
of neutral and they I mean I think that
they couldn't have thought we were gonna
do anything we were just two Yahoo's
from San Francisco and eventually we
testified at 2:00 in the morning in
front of a subcommittee in Texas they're
the big the big stuff that they were
hearing in the subcommittee at the time
was TX use act was the acquisition of
TXU by the big private equity firms TPG
and KKR and then we got to testify and
we told them we're gonna start this
company and we're gonna help people get
better information about their utilities
and and long long story
slightly less long
Rick Perry signed it into law everything
in that bill HB 36 93 was anything of
any import standard appliance standards
building standards were all stripped out
of the bill because some lobbyists or
another had objected to it but our
little provision that said home
electricity port reports shall count
towards energy efficiency standards in
the state of Texas remained unscathed
the legislation passed dan and I shared
a high-five of maybe a drink or two and
we said we use this concept that Dan had
a corny but very useful concept which
was we decided to hit the Go button
we had come into this and I think this
is a useful concept for entrepreneurs
we'd come into it with five or six ideas
and the idea was let's try and convince
ourselves that these ideas won't work
and we spent the first four months of
working together trying to pick holes in
our own ideas trying to find some
compelling reason why we shouldn't start
the business but once we once that
legislation in Texas passed and we hit
the Go button we we dropped the other
ideas and instead of poking holes in our
own idea we started to say we decided to
make our own idea impervious to any kind
of criticism and our entire focus became
making this a success so that's more
than you asked for but that's how we
started I mean what you just described
is a concept of customer discovery but
yeah you should be your harshest critic
by the way talking about political
spectrum you see a little you know just
jointed it red socks blue I'm just
saying
well I'm trying to you know somebody you
want to run right public office some day
I get it now I'm getting so no starting
a company is a daunting task and can be
very very lonely for those of you had
done it and so we always advise young
entrepreneurs to have a co-founder right
but choose wisely right we say sometimes
many times choosing your co-founders a
more difficult choice than choosing your
spouse and so you had a great co-founder
it sounds like Dan
so tell me about that process of the
relationship with DES
and the decision to go into business
with Dan sure and what it meant for
Opower
I'm not going to get into trouble by
either confirming or refuting your your
assert a ssin that's a more difficult
decision than finding a spouse but I it
is it's an important decision you know I
think Dan I remain good friends we were
good friends when we started the
business I don't think that's a
necessity but it was certainly great for
us I think generally speaking if I were
to provide certain advice I would say
that certainly I agree with your advice
that starting a business alone I would
never do it starting a business with a
co-founder I think is necessary both
because the good times are more than
twice as good when there's two of you to
celebrate and the bad times are easily
less as less than half as hard when you
have someone to commiserate with and to
share the experience with and Dan and I
I think we're great partners and great
co-founders because we both respect one
another a lot and admire each other's
strengths and we have a shared set of
values and passions we wanted to start
this business not for the business's
sake but to have a positive impact on
the environment but our experience and
skills and strengths are basically not
overlapped so I see a lot of people go
into business together with somebody who
has a very shared set of experiences or
maybe they come out of the same graduate
program and then I'm a little leery of
Dan's an engineer he's a computer
scientist he is incredibly organized and
disciplined I'm less so and you know we
have we just have different proclivities
and different interests and different
talents and we both respected one
another's talents but but but allow it
enabled each other to pursue our own
that goes along with the hacker hustler
designer model for the optimal team for
startups so that that's great if you
haven't already and you'd like to ask a
question if you can please start to text
them in
I have one more question for Alex and
then we'll get to the audience's
questions and any problem we're solving
in the world somebody's always already
trying to solve it and I think that was
probably true of this issue that Opower
went after so there's direct competition
or indirect competition but as a
disrupter you're always going to butt up
against the incumbents what was your
strategy for dealing with the incumbents
and and how did you go about that yeah I
guess I would say that in our case
there's sort of two sets of incumbents
that are worth discussing one are the
other software companies that provide
software to the utility industry and
Oracle being one of them but not the
only only one the other being the
utilities themselves who are the
incumbent energy providers and in in
many cases could have been our fiercest
competitors in that you know so the
choice not to work with us would have
been maybe a choice to go it alone
we made the decision early on that the
utilities though not sexy or necessarily
than the most nimble partners were the
obvious path to market for us and I said
at the beginning we we started with the
premise that most people want to save
energy and next and nobody thinks about
it and so with that in mind we decided
the only way to bring new information
services to market was to partner with
the incumbents partner with utilities
and to help them innovate and to do
things differently than they had done in
the past at the time the the companies
in sort of clean tech space were I guess
most of them were focused on the supply
side so most of them were focused on
renewable energy and and you know
changing the way energy is produced we
were one of the few companies that were
focused on the other half of the
equation which is changing the way
energy is consumed of the companies that
were focused on the way energy was
consumed nearly all of them except us
were focused on sort of going around or
disrupting the utility and even
Microsoft and Google shortly after we
star
the company launched their own
competitive services to ours but there's
both relied on direct-to-consumer
relationship and they both failed and
not because they're not smart but
because I think that a fundamental
decision to work with the utilities as
frustrating is that sometimes was was
the among the smartest decisions we made
and so you know I think Dave and his
talk talked about this 80-ton gap and he
he sort of on the one hand dismissed you
know he said we're gonna focus on the 40
tons that need what needs new
breakthrough technologies and he sort of
dismissed the others as the existing
technology that needs to scale you know
I would urge you budding entrepreneurs
out there to not dismiss that that half
of the equation that there is the best
technologies don't always scale and they
don't always scale at the speed in which
society and in our case civilization
demands that they scale it and this this
sector clean tech clean energy
environment needs entrepreneurs who are
going to help the incumbents and other
existing providers scale up existing
technology and there's a lot of money to
be made there and and more importantly
there's a lot of impact to be had there
so I would just say that and then
quickly on the other incumbents the
existing software providers and other
providers the utilities we sort of went
unnoticed by them until we became
reasonably big because we sold to
business buyers not to IT and we sold
specifically to departments where they
had never bought software before so we
sold to energy efficiency buyers who
heretofore had spent money exclusively
on buying down the price of LEDs or on
subsidizing your HVAC replacement in
your home or your business and they were
buying hardware or subsidizing hardware
instead of buying software so we had
built up a busy
that was well over 100 million dollars
in recurring sass revenue before we had
many meaningful relationships with the
CIOs of the utilities and before the
Oracles and si PS of the world even knew
we were there
we're getting some really great
questions so we'll try to get to all of
them or maybe even bundle a couple of
them together but I want to give credit
to the first person that asked the
question which is having a legislation
passed that would support your product
how critical do you think that played in
the future of your product as it evolved
so I it's a great question
and it allows me to tell the coda to
that story which is that I told you that
Brian Mooar did paloalto told us he'd be
his first customer via our first
customer and that we had gotten Texas
which is by population the second and
which was the sort of critical measure
for us the second largest state in the
country to pass legislation that would
allow utilities to work with us Palo
Alto was our 23rd or 24th utility
customer and we never in nine years got
a deal in Texas so the short answer on
the question of how important was that
legislation in Texas is that it was not
important at all it didn't none of our
business came from Texas but of course
the signal that sent us maybe it was you
know in itself was a false positive was
a critically important signal that let
us know that one that we could have fun
working together it was really fun to go
and live together in a crummy motel room
in Texas and do this and that we
convinced people who were very different
from us that this was a good idea and to
that that ultimately we would have we
could have a scaled and we would have a
scaled impact even in places that were
culturally very different than the
places we lived and in fact a powered
business at the time of the acquisition
you know was was not only in in
California and Massachusetts and in the
sort of blue states but we did a lot of
business in in parts of the country that
politically very conservative in fact
our best-performing project well yeah
yeah I'm actually even try to bundle
these next three questions were together
because they have a similar thread
slightly different it has to do with
challenges and difficulties that you
faced the first part of that is
utilities oh my god they've got to be
was the most bureaucratic organizations
in the world and and the sale cyclists
are very very long so you know those had
to be among some of the challenges that
you faced early on as the nobody that
nobody said right yeah and you know
along with those challenges what are
some of the other big challenges you
faced early and how did you overcome
them yeah I guess that is a question I
get and it is an intuition that people
have and it's it's true utilities don't
move quickly
they are bureaucratic but there are a
lot of them they're not competitive with
one another for the most part and and
they're willing to hear new ideas so you
know it in on the one hand it takes a
long time with any one of them but on
the other hand you have a lot of
utilities to go after and I'm a kind of
person who'd never here's know when I
could perhaps here maybe or maybe later
and so I spent well I spent the whole
decade I hunt more than one hundred and
fifty nine hundred and sixty nights a
year away from home but I spent those
first couple years on the road meeting
with utilities and never taking no for
an answer and you know once and we never
gave any what anything away for free our
first project were paid projects which I
advise entrepreneurs that you know
people value what they paid for and they
don't value what they don't pay for but
we did get a few utilities to say yes
SMUD in Sacramento which in spite of its
name is a is a very well-regarded
leading utility was our first customer
with Puget Sound Energy and up in the
Seattle area a bunch of utilities in
Minnesota
SoCal Edison San Diego Gas and Electric
these were among our first
customers who took a real bet on us when
we didn't have any results but
eventually we had results and utilities
are in those sort of results business
they have they have to deliver on
commitments that they make to their
customers to their shareholders and
ultimately also to their regulators and
we help them make good on those
commitments and so the nice thing about
working with utilities is that they are
results oriented they have tremendous
scale and so yeah things can be a little
frustrating at times but they are
ultimately very loyal and good customers
once you acquire them as customers so I
would you know I wouldn't I would
encourage people to not be shy when
thinking about who they want to partner
with what was the average sales cycle
length oh it changed and dependent on
this on the type of product we were
selling but the average sales cycle was
roughly 15 months the average sale was
was ultimately by you know our first
sale was for nearly $400,000 and the end
the overtime the average sale crept up
to just shy of a million dollars was a
SAS model or was a SAS model that's
great so that's yeah so I was annual
revenue and so these were big deals and
they take a long time and the 15 months
hides the fact that some of our sales
took well over four or five years but
but it's you know that includes deals
that were expansions and new SKUs into
existing customers which were faster
than 50 bucks right that sort of fits
with Jeffrey Moore's crossing the chasm
you know that mainstream customer is not
going to buy until there's evidence that
it's working with pressure so that
that's natural this is a great question
because you know your product was
designed to reduce consumption but
didn't that reduce revenue yeah utility
and how did you navigate that
conversation I realized also that we
didn't answer I didn't answer I don't
mean to suggest that I don't mean to
impugn you but there was a quote the
part of your other question was what
other challenges we face
which I can happy to try and answer so
the the reason that utilities were
interested in helping their customers
save energy is that utilities are
regulated and in spite of what folks in
Washington DC will now have you believe
regulation is not always bad and you in
this industry regulation has aligned the
utility interests with the public
interests since the advent of the
utility it's been more than a hundred
years since I think it was in Wisconsin
first a legislation was passed that
mandated that the utilities there not
just bring electricity to wealthy
households but bring electricity to
every household and you know this is a
business operating on its own might not
bring electricity to the poorest
neighborhoods of a city but with
regulation it's serving the public
interest and the Tennessee Valley
Authority is another example of this
bringing electricity to everybody and in
doing so lifting millions of people out
of poverty so that wasn't the
legislation of the regulation that we
followed on but but it's important to
remember that this is a lot this utility
industry has a long and storied history
of pursuing the public interest because
of policy in our case it started in
California in the early 80s but
utilities profits are regulated and as a
consequence in California what utilities
were essentially profits and revenues
were decoupled as the word which is to
say that and I'm gonna oversimplify but
utilities were allowed to earn a higher
rate of return if they could demonstrate
that they were helping their customers
save energy here in Pennsylvania there's
act 129 which puts an obligation on the
utilities to to help provide energy
efficiency to their customers in some
cases there's a bonus associated with
doing in other cases there's a penalty
associated with not doing it but just to
illustrate in an oversimplified example
if utilities making a 10% margin on the
commodity that they're selling and
they're told by their regulators if you
reduce consumption by five percent will
allow you to earn an 11 percent return
all of a sudden the profit for the
utility would go up but the total
revenue would go down and essentially
for the for an average customer if their
bill was $100 before now their bill is
$96 and if the utilities profit was ten
dollars before now their bill is now
their profit is you know ten seventy or
whatever the I'm doing the math
incorrectly but that's roughly it and so
everybody wins except for the guy with
the powerplant but that is that
legislation existed in in different
versions of that kind of regulation
existed in about twelve states when we
started the business in 2007 and today
even in Mississippi there's legislation
that that that puts that and I think
it's something like 42 states now have
energy efficiency requirements or
obligations or incentives for their
utilities this is more of a comment from
Scott Cola thank you Scott said my
Duquesne Light email came through during
your discussion thank you for your drive
and nice touch
how about that hmm that's right I don't
know what to make of the fact that
Scott's checking his email during our
talk so it's double edged but yeah
you're welcome
Touche uh your product deals with data
so how difficult was it to get the data
from the utilities and how did this you
know hinder the the timeframe in which
you deliver the value through their
bills well we said we we started the
company at a time where there was far
less data about individual consumption
than there is today and thankfully we
built the architecture of our our
systems in such a way that we could
accommodate the influx of new data at
the time when we started the business
the standard and every utility in the
country was that household energy
consumption was checked once every 30
days in some cases actually once every
two months by a person who went around
and checked the meter today in much of
the country including here in Pittsburgh
energy data is collected every 15
minutes by the utility and that's
overall usage data and then of course
lots of people have smart
devices in their homes which is
collecting data and we could get our
hands on some of that data at the sub
second level and so from the very GetGo
our sort of thesis was nobody wants to
see their data
nobody we're all overwhelmed by data as
it is and nobody wants to see an EKG of
their energy use
people want insights and analysis that
that's that can be provided from that
data and so whether you're getting data
once a month and that allows you some
insights and about how a customer uses
energy seasonally and it's actually
pretty interesting even with monthly
data you can you can tell somebody like
will your your your efficient during
most of the year but in the summertime
you're using 40% more than your
neighbors and here are some
recommendations we have to help you with
your HVAC usage from changing your
thermostat settings to calling this
number to have somebody come in and
services and anything in between
changing the filters and so on and so
forth and so even with monthly data
especially when we combine it with other
data that we were able to get our hands
on so hourly temperature and humidity
data from thousands of local weather
stations GIS data housing data from the
County Assessor's Office all this data
together gave us a rich picture of the
customer the more data we had the more
interesting the products and services we
could provide were today I think it
Duchaine customers are now getting
alerts and certainly elsewhere in the
country alerts emails and text messages
in as few as eight days into the month
you're on track in text message that
says you're on track for a bill that's
30% higher than your typical bill for
this time of year here are some things
you could do to reduce your energy
consumption and you know that was only
made possible because of the advent of
new data sources and our ability to
process it so yeah very cool my good
friend Bruce Kevlar did letter earlier
panel call no power the biggest
behavioral science experiment of all
time right and this question gets to it
the question is why is comparison to
others more effective than monetary
incentives to lower
consumption there's a hole there
competing theories about about sort of
generally speaking why that's the case
but it is the case not just an energy
but elsewhere but in energy it's
actually sort of relatively
straightforward in the US the average
household spends less than 1.7 percent
of its of its budget on electricity 1.7
percent so the idea that that I could
come to you and can try and get you to
pay attention to something that's going
to reduce that 1.7 percent to 1.6
percent is you know it's it's just not
enough money people don't even pay
attention to their to their financial
accounts they don't pay attention to you
know their 401ks it's it's the idea that
they're gonna pay attention to their
utility bill because it's gonna help
them save money is is a bit too much to
ask of folks and so it turns out that
you know we have half a million years of
evolutionary history that that pushes us
to compare our behavior to others to
stay with the pack and this is
particularly true for you know the
behavioral scientists will tell you that
we make thousands of decisions I think
that something like three or four
thousand decisions every day some of
them were conscious of what what do I
want for breakfast
you know what clothing am I gonna put on
this morning what am I gonna do when my
kid doesn't listen to me
which way am I gonna drive you know
there are all kinds of decisions not to
mention sort of the important decisions
about what am I going to do with work
and what Who am I going to marry Who am
I going to work with we make tons of
tiny decisions am I gonna walk this way
or that which line am I gonna get into
in the lunchroom what am I going to eat
and for the decisions that matter less
and the decisions for which we have less
visibility the safe and reasonable thing
to do is to do what other people do and
when it comes to household energy use
which is something that doesn't matter
that much what we don't historically
have a lot of visibility into what other
people do so providing a social norm was
a very useful and
remained a very useful way at guiding
and shaping behavior so this is a
standard great entrepreneurship question
what was your biggest mistake and why as
you look back over the nine years that
you were running this company what do
you look back and said wish I wish I
would have done this differently well we
made a lot of mistakes I the I think the
biggest mistakes we made generally could
be categorized as mistakes where we
something wasn't working we knew it
wasn't working and we stuck with it in
spite of that maybe because we felt some
sense of loyalty to the idea even our
idea
maybe it's because stopping doing it and
then firing somebody or or reordan
you know we would have to let somebody
go who we felt some loyalty to but we
were not fast enough it's shutting
things down
that weren't working as well as we'd
like them to and I think that was
probably if I could categorize generally
the biggest the biggest mistake we made
I don't know that we wouldn't do it make
those same mistakes again or that I
wouldn't make those same mistakes again
if I started another business but it's
it's difficult it's difficult to to say
you know say goodbye to something that
you think you had thought was going to
work and any particular one oh yeah a
number of things we had a partnership
with Honeywell to design a smart
thermostat to be the the the app and and
we launched roughly at the same time as
nest and our partnership emu company by
the way just saying and unlike nest
which took a direct consumer approach
our approach again involved partnership
with utilities but it also involved a
partnership with Honeywell which was a
large incumbent slow-moving bureaucratic
bureaucracy and it involved partnership
with installers HVAC installers which as
a group were also resistant to change
and there were just a lot of moving
parts that didn't move as quickly as we
needed them to move
and you know we spent a lot of resources
on it we had an app that was had a
better NPS than the nest app we were
saving measurable amounts of energy on
paper it should have worked
and it didn't and we that was one thing
we went international earlier than we
probably should have and we did it in a
way that was very opportunistic rather
than strategic which meant that I have a
passport that's four times as thick as
as the new you know normal passport and
spent a lot of time in lots of different
far-flung places and we landed a lot of
deals but those deals over time weren't
necessarily profitable or sustainable
was that driven by the desire to go
public or you were public no know what
it wasn't ruined by the desire to go
public it was driven by the desire to
have a big impact and so you know and
maybe it was desired by some it was
driven by some like desire to spend time
traveling around the world completely
honest about it but know we had we know
we you know we landed a deal in the UK
while we were doing that I'm you know I
met whatever you know we had deals all
over the world and it was a little less
focused than you know I'll give you an
example of this and in in when Fukushima
happened in 2011 I went to our board and
said we'd like to go to Japan they're
gonna have this huge need for energy
efficiency this is an island country
that has no natural resources not a
particularly good target for renewables
and they're about to shut down their
nuclear plants energy efficiency is
going to be something that they they
pursue and our boards which was mostly
made up of software investors said no
way you know nobody can do business in
Japan it's a very difficult market you
can't do it alone you have to do with a
partner and so on and so forth and you
guys have to demonstrate to us that you
can do business in more than one country
before you go to Japan well in the next
six months we landed contracts in
Australia and New Zealand in
Swit Sweden in France and I went back to
the board and I said look I've been all
over the world we've done all his
business please let me go to Japan and
try and get a deal done and they let it
they let me go and we we did land a deal
and with TEPCO and it was a large deal
but we weren't we weren't a mature
enough company to service that deal
eventually the deal disappeared I mean
that the deal but the relationship with
the client disappeared and the market
for energy efficiency did not flourish
one of the great things about the Oracle
partnership when it happened was that it
allowed us to sort of resuscitate our
Japanese business and I was just in
Japan after leaving Oracle I went with
Oracle to Japan in October and helped
close a deal there and we're now working
with or they're now working with six
utilities across Japan finally to bring
energy efficiency and the project is
working better than any other project in
the world has worked and it's a
multi-million dollar project but it was
but it's nearly you know six and a half
years later so there's a lot of there
was a lot of costs and headaches and
pain that wasn't necessarily good for us
that we endure it in those in those
years doesn't kill you makes you
stronger right
so as we're about that I have a couple
of questions along the silk yeah okay so
Opower is now in your rear view mirror
great run what gets you excited about
what's happening in this space right
what are you looking at well at the
moment I'm not looking in with interest
at any one particular thing I'm this is
my last time away from home my wife is
due May first and so this was like
cutting it pretty close to I need to get
home and I'm gonna focus on remembering
how to swaddle a baby and practice not
sleeping and so that's what I'm focused
on at the moment but this is a space and
an industry that I'm super excited about
and I read somebody earlier today
mentioned Paul Hawkens book drawdown I
read
with interest I thought it was sort of
inadequately described though it is the
research was to identify what are the
hundred things that could help us
actually close the gap to maintain no
more than a two degree increase in
global temperatures and there's a lot of
interesting and sort of surprising stuff
in that book I'm particularly fascinated
I find myself really excited about food
and food waste it turned that we started
the business I hadn't I think it was
only in in the process of running the
business that I realized I had a real
like biological genetic obsession with
with waste I really don't like wasting
things I don't like people leaving the
lights on when they when they're not in
the room and I also don't like food
going to waste so I'm I don't yet have
any ideas but I'm like I am super
excited Dave mentioned it also I think
4.4 gigatonnes of carbon from food waste
so it's a big and thorny problem a
smelly problem I guess so but that but I
have to I have no ideas I'm super
excited though to hear what people are
working on it you see any interesting
things there companies are going around
food ways to I haven't seen anything but
I haven't really you know what one one
thing is spending all this time overseas
we waste a lot more food in this country
than people waste in other countries and
there's still a lot of waste in those
countries too but we we waste more food
in this country than is consumed in
Europe every day we and that waste
happens on the the farm fields and it
happens in the supermarkets and it
happens in our own refrigerators in one
of the ways it's wasted is that we are
where have become you know a Costco
culture we have big SUVs and they drive
us to Costco and you know when the thing
that's three times as large costs only
50 percent more than the thing that's
the size we actually need we can't
afford not to buy the thing that's three
times as large so we buy three gallons
of milk when when 1/2 a gallon of milk
will do and some of that milk goes to
waste and so you know I think some of
this gets at policy and pricing
you know if you live in a smaller home
with a smaller refrigerator and you
don't drive to the supermarket but you
walk to the supermarket it doesn't
matter how cheap the two gallon you know
jug of milk is you're not bringing it
home it's to one gallon jugs of milk but
so you know I some of it as cultural
some of it is is a function of sort of
the luxury that we live in in this
country but you know I don't I don't I
haven't seen any companies yet but I'd
be excited to learn there's some really
cool grassroots effort like here in
Pittsburgh there's one of our CMU alums
has a company called for one to food
rescue and trying to use grassroots
people volunteering their time to go
gather up that food waste from
restaurants and that instrument it
that's also homeless and things of that
nature so they probably need help but
you know logistically how do you scale
that right so um back to the political
side of things since that's where you
got your start what type of energy
regulations or policies would you like
to see put in place that would have made
your life easier and Oh power and would
make everybody's lives better going
forward well I'd say one thing is that
I'm I'm quite optimistic about the
policy landscape and not because I'm
blind to the news in Washington but
because I'm attentive to the news in
Lancaster and in in state capitals
across this country because that's where
a lot of the important policy is made is
is in state houses in City Hall's those
are the policies that affect
transportation to affect electricity
consumption and distribution that affect
all kinds of other things and so I would
say that you know I think it's it's easy
to be cynical and critical and negative
but there's a lot of good stuff
happening and some of it I think is
happening in response to what's not
happening in DC that said there's it was
raised earlier on a panel but a carbon
tax is the most obvious way to price the
societal cost of how we do business
and I'm not I'm not
holy you know cynical or negative about
that either this is we have a federal
government that is going to be in need
of revenues after the tax bill that was
passed and we're gonna need to raise
revenues to pay for our obligations
because not all those obligations in
spite of what some people in Washington
would want the federal government is not
going to walk away from all their
obligations so just politically not
going to be able to walk away from
entitlement obligations and so on and so
they need to raise revenue somewhere in
a carbon tax makes a lot of sense for
raising that revenue and I think there
are Republicans in Congress who in their
heart of hearts realize this do you
think there's entrepreneurial
opportunities around carbon tax you know
are there you know what what what's a
flyer idea around that oh well there are
regional carbon taxes or cap-and-trade
things being put in place in different
places and I think that's exciting there
are cities that are talking about it you
know I guess another policy which
doesn't involve the federal government
which I'm super excited is is something
that is beginning to happen slowly we
talked about the smart meters that are
in place now that read electricity every
15 minutes one of the potential
opportunities on the back of those smart
meters is to price electricity variable
pricing depending on the time of day or
the time of season the season of the
year that that electricity is being
consumed and so California is moving I
think next calendar year 2019 moving all
customers and all residential customers
to a time-of-use pricing so instead of
paying a flat rate for electricity or in
their case a tiered rate for electricity
they're going to be charging people in a
more rational way based on when in the
day they use it and what the spot prices
you know I went to the only time I went
to the Consumer Electronics Show in Las
Vegas was January of 2001 and the only
the the conference the focus of the
conference was about the smart home
everybody was going to have a server in
their home and there every device in the
home is going to be connected for the
internet and we're going to have a
refrigerator that tells us when we're
out of milk
and you know all this stuff which still
hasn't come to fruition in spite of Matt
Rogers and the folks at nest the
relatively few of our devices are smart
and and relatively few people have those
smart devices and that in my opinion has
the ability to radically change if if we
were to be paying for electricity on a
variable pricing because all of a sudden
it would make sense to replace our
refrigerator maybe not with a
refrigerator that told us we're out of
milk but with a refrigerator that made
ice at the times when the electricity
was cheap and and and let itself warm up
modestly at times when the electricity
was expensive and so all of a sudden our
homes could become a lot smarter and the
economic value in exchanging your
existing appliances the case would be a
lot stronger if we had cured
I mean time-of-use electricity pricing
and that's the kind of thing that can be
pushed for at the state level and that I
think there's a lot of entrepreneurial
opportunity that are equal so I have a
one final question because we're running
out of time and I always ask this
question to entrepreneurs to answer for
aspiring entrepreneurs there's lots of
advice that you can give to
entrepreneurs but if you had to boil it
down to one priority piece of advice
what would that be for entrepreneurs
well the thing that immediately comes to
mind is maybe something that doesn't
need repeating for this audience because
of where you are and what why you're
here but I would say that there are a
lot of businesses to start there's a lot
of money to be made but there are also a
lot of ways to waste your time and if
you're going to start a business and go
through the sort of difficulties that
that entails and the sacrifices that
you'll inevitably make to your personal
life and your family and that you should
you should do it with some for something
that actually matters something that's
gonna make the world a better place
because chances are you're not going to
succeed
and you know wasting your time or not
wasting your time working really hard on
something because it allows for
advertising to get served more quickly
is you know would be that would be a
real shame better to work really hard
and in a focused and dedicated way on
something that might wait but make the
world a better place and so and I would
always keep that top of mind I mean
you're gonna if we started the business
to have a positive impact on the
environment to reduce energy consumption
we were able to measure and track that
over time thankfully in our case our
double bottom-line interests were very
well aligned but having that having that
second bottom line having the thing that
that gets you up in the morning even on
the days that you're most frustrated or
when you're waking up in a hotel in some
strange city I think is a critical as a
critical part of of motivating yourself
of attracting and motivating your
colleagues and employees and that would
be my my biggest piece of advice is to
try and do something that actually
matters that's great insight and wisdom
thank you Alex thank you thanks a lot
[Applause]
thank you of course so thank you again
Alex for that awesome conversation very
glad to have you on campus a little bit
of housekeeping before we leave today we
are ending well we have actually one
more thing before we end we're ending in
this room but we do have a reception
this evening it's from six until eight
o'clock so we are almost late it's in
Scott Hall which is a short walk across
campus from here it's it's where the
Scott Institute is all the time so we
want to make sure that you join us
across campus it's on the fifth floor
which is ground level if you're coming
from campus in the marquee room tomorrow
morning we start at 10 o'clock we have
Andrew place who is the vice chairman of
the Pennsylvania Public Utilities
Commission talking interestingly enough
about the price of carbon one of his
favorite topics
at 11:15 we have Chris White who is the
CEO the newly named CEO of philips
Lighting who will be our keynote in
between those we have an English
monologue so again sort of focusing on
the multidisciplinary nature of Carnegie
Mellon and our Allegheny clean tech
competition starts tomorrow where we'll
have opportunities to see one minute
pitches opportunities to see the final
pitches later in the day many of you are
judges we have tours in the middle of
the day and a speaker from Tata
Consultancy tomorrow evening there's a
lot of activities so looking forward to
seeing you on day three please join us
for the reception
three or four minutes outside on campus
thanks very much